S Stéphanie Grandmont,
MiMichel C. Auger
etet Christian Dufour.
BoBonsoir.
VoVous aurez noté qu'on peut alr
prprendre une bière en Abitibi.
LeLes bars sont ouverts. Le
rerestaurant l'était, mais ils
sosont en sondes jaunes. On tend
vevers ça tranquillement. On n'n
rereparlera. Aujourd'hui, deux
susujets : la réforme de la loi
élélectorale. Michel C. Auger,
esest-ce que c'est normal que
l'l'opposition dit : on va prene
lele temps d'en parler, parce
ququ'on veut ajuster trois jours
popour voter par exemple et
d'd'autres mesures dans le CHSL.
QuQu'est-ce qui se passe d'après
vovous?
- - Il s'est parce qu'il se pase
nonormalement quand les députés
cocommencent à se rendre compte
quque ça va être pas mal un des
dederniers projets de loi qui va
êêtre déposée avant qu'il y ait
unune élection. Je ne suis pas n
trtrain de vous dire qu'il va y
avavoir une élection ce printem,
mamais à un moment donné, il vay
avavoir un ajournement de la
chchambre au mois de juin et
prprobablement que de nouveaux
dédéputés vont siéger. Il deviet
didifficile pour faire adopter
n'n'importe quel projet de loi t
bibien sûre, dans le parti
coconservateur, on dit : est-ce
quque ce favorable pour nous
d'd'avoir trois jours de vote? s
dodoivent se dire : on va essayr
dede faire porter le chapeau au
paparti au pouvoir d'autant que
leles libéraux doivent être ten.
LeLes derniers sondages de ce
mamatin, 10 points d'avance les
coconservateurs. Il y en a qui
dodoive être tenté.
- - Ils rongent leur frein.
SoSouhaite en même temps, pour e
gogouvernement, adopter ce projt
dede loi, c'est dire : on comprd
ququ'il y a un problème avec la
papandémie.
- - Stéphanie, comment vous
cocomprenez le débat qui se jouà
OtOttawa?
- - Je comprends aussi qu'il y a
dedes élections dans la. On n'a
papas de date, mais si on se
sosouvient, dans le budget qui a
étété déposé il y a quelques
sesemaines, il y avait quand mêe
unun cadeau de 500 $, ce qui va
êêtre envoyé au mois d'août à
totous les années de 75 ans et
plplus : c'est vraiment du
mamarketing électoral. Ça nous..
ququand ce chèque va arriver au
momois d'août, on pourrait
imimaginer que peut-être il y
auaurait des élections un peu
apaprès. Évidemment, ce sont des
susuppositions. Quand même, les
lilibéraux sont probablement en
trtrain de mettre le terrain. Iy
a a un entonnoir du fait qu'il
rereste cinq semaines avant la
popose estivale. Il y a plusieus
prprojets qui essaient de
dedescendre et ça crée un goulot
d'd'étranglement. Mais oui,
efeffectivement, d'avoir des
memesures sanitaires plus adapts
àà une élection entendait
papandémie, ça paraît raisonnab.
- - Sur le fond Christian,
popourquoi pas?
- - Sa le problème de
l'l'argumentaire des partis
d'd'opposition, c'est qu'il n'ya
papas vraiment de différence sur
lele fond du projet de loi qui t
avavant tout technique qui est e
rerecommandation du directeur
gégénéral des élections. Les
lilibéraux ont réussi quelque
chchose. Il veulent seraient
dodonnés la possibilité de donnr
dedes élections dans un contexte
fafavorable. Comme le dit
StStéphanie, dans une optique pe
papartisane, dans une optique
d'd'intérêt public, ce n'est pas
fufutile tandis que la pandémiee
prprolonge, dure plus longtemps
quque prévu pour s'organiser et
ororganiser des élections. La ve
cocontinue. Les libéraux ont
réréussi quelque chose sous
cocouvert d'intérêt public en
paparti objejectif est. Il se
reredonne une marge de manoeuvre
popour tenir des élections qu'is
veveulent manifestement.
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chchef, Bloc québécois
- - Le gouvernement suspend
leles règles de la démocratie
popour changer les règles
dede la démocratie. On change ps
leles règles d'une partie
dede hockey au milieu de la pare
sisi les deux équipes sont pas
d'd'accord! Alors, je ne vois
auaucune justification et s'il
y y en a une, il faudra que
ququelqu'un le demande au premir
miministre pour procéder par
bbâillon sur une loi fondamentae
dede l'exercice de la démocrati.
ALALAIN THERRIEN, député, BQ
LaLa Prairie, Qc
- - C'est extrêmement inquiétant
dede voir le gouvernement imposr
unun bâillon pour modifier
seses règles électorales en plee
papandémie. C'était pas urgent
pependant quatre mois. Qu'est-ce
ququi justifie soudainement
lele bâillon? C'est-tu parce
ququ'ils veulent aller en électn
dudurant une pandémie.
DODOMINIC LeBLANC, ministre féd,
AfAffaires intergouvernementales
- - Nous avons cru aussi bon de
rérépondre au rapport du Directr
gégénéral des élections qui a
dedemandé au Parlement en octobe
dede présenter des modifications
àà la loi électorale temporaire
popour s'assurer qu'une élection
pupuisse se faire dans le contee
dede la pandémie. Et c'est ça qe
nonous sommes en train de faire.
- - On a l'impression que les
lilibéraux veulent y aller et
l'l'opposition n'est pas trop
tetentée.
- - En même temps, vous savez,
ququand Monsieur Blanchet dit :n
veveut modifier les règles de la
dédémocratie, il parle des
cacarottés d'orge. On va utilisr
lele bâillon pour passer un prot
dede loi. C'est dans le règlemet
dede la chambre. C'est pas
agagréable, mais c'est dans les
rrèglements. En amont de la loi
élélectorale de façon temporaire
popour faire face à la situation
sasanitaire. Ce n'est pas... ily
a a pas grand monde vont trouver
çaça exagéré.
- - Je veux vous entendre sur dx
prprojets de transport en commun
imimporte tant pour tout le Quéc
: : le prolongement de la ligne
blbleue e et le Remme délaissen:
ilil y a eu beaucoup de brouhaha
paparce que les gens disent : on
ne veut pas de portions
aéaériennes au centre-ville. Je
vovous fais entendre Monsieur
ArArbaud à la caisse qui dit qun
nene peut pas aller en souterra.
IlIl dit que ça va être des tras
sisilencieux. On écoute.
JEJEAN-MARC ARBAUD, président
etet chef, direction, CDPQ Infra
- - Pour aller de l'est au cente
dede Montréal, on se retrouve
àà croiser beaucoup d'ouvrage.
CeCertains des aqueducs qui
fofonctionnent, certains par
grgravité, donc qui sont pas
dédéplaçables, qui sont plus
quque centenaires. Trois lignes
dede métro, la 720... Donc, on a
reregardé différentes solutions,
popossibilités, comment faire
avavec différentes techniques
popour aller au centre-ville
dede Montréal, mais c'est
vrvraiment... ça pose énormément
d'd'enjeux techniques.
- - C'est sur la portion aériene
dudu centre-ville. Tour de tabl.
StStéphanie, on a l'impression e
lele REM avance. Parallèlement à
çaça, la ligne bleue n'a pas le
mmême pilote dans l'avion et
scscellant. On nous annonce
d'd'autres dépassements de coût.
CoComment vous voyez ça?
- - D'un côté, on a l'impression
quque la ligne bleue, ça va trop
lelentement. C'est depuis 1979 n
enen parle. De dire que ça avane
dede à pas de tortue, c'est
jujustifié. Et d'autre part, du
ccôté du Remme délesté, on a
l'l'impression qu'on met un peue
lala charrue devant les boeufs,
paparce qu'on la caisse des
dédépôts, CDPQ Infra a des
popouvoirs que le gouvernement i
a a conférés qui sont différents
etet qui lui permettent d'aller
plplus vite. Évidemment, le prot
popose toutes sortes de questios
susur notamment est-ce que ça va
êêtre en plein centre-ville alos
ququ'on est en train de rabaissr
leles infrastructures, enlever e
bébéton, défaire les échangeurs.
EsEst-ce qu'on va se retrouver
avavec une autoroute
mémétropolitaine en plein centr-
viville?
- - Vous avait l'impression quea
vava trop vite le REM?
- - On a peu de transparence por
l'l'instant et on n'a pas
nénécessairement... on n'a pas
l'l'impression que les deux
prprojets sont arrimés. C'est un
enenjeu, parce que c'est un résu
dede transport, il faut que tout
çaça fonctionne ensemble et c'et
papas clair qu'on à ce sentiment
enen ce moment.
- - Michel, je pense que vous
alallez dire que vous trouvez qe
çaça va peut-être trop vite, qul
y y a un manque de transparenceu
ccôté du REM, mais les autres
prprojets, que ça soit sur qui
neneuf, la voie réservée, la lie
blbleue, ça fait 40 ans qu'on en
paparle, alors d'un côté, il y a
lala lenteur que ça se fait past
dede l'autre côté, ça c'est fai.
SoSouhaite à chaque fois, que ce
sosoit pin-up ou la ligne bleue,
ilil y a un gouvernement qui
ararrive et qui dit : ça ne va
papas, je vais te la faire, ça
cocoûte trop cher. On a tellemet
sosouvent joué dans le film qu'n
vava abandonner le projet de lie
blbleue d'ici l'automne et on va
didire : regardez, le REM, lui,l
mamarche. On lui donne ses
exexpropriations. Les choses ne
sosont pas comparables. On va
esessayer de les comparer et ona
tutuer encore une fois la ligne
blbleue. Je me souviens papas dn
gogouvernement sauf celui de
MaMadame Marois qui était sériex
dadans son intention de prolongr
lala ligne bleue. À chaque fois,
ilils ont essayé de la tuer.
- - Pour vous, ça ne se fera pa?
- - La ligne bleue, je crains
fofortement que ça ne se fasse
papas. Le REM, ils vont bulldoz,
ilils sont en train de le faire.
- - Ce qui ressort, c'est le
mamanque d'arrimage entre ces
dedeux. En ce qui a trait à la
liligne bleue, je ne sais pas si
çaça va se réaliser ou pas, mais
ququelque chose ressort beaucou,
àà quel point c'est surréaliste,
l'l'organisation de ce projet. n
nonous parle de 14 comités. C'et
bebeaucoup. Des délais, de
coconfusion, de labyrinthe. Il y
a a pas de pilote dans l'avion.
C'C'est le titre de l'article. s
1414 comités sont comme un peu à
lala dérive et ça ramène à une e
memes obsessions, vous allez me
didire, c'est qu'au Québec, ça
cocommence à faire beaucoup
d'd'infrastructures
bubureaucratiques qui ne sont ps
cacapables de livrer la
mamarchandise. On a vu ce que
c'c'était en santé.
- - C'est ça mon point. Le REM,
paparce qu'ils sont plus
efefficaces, en même temps, ça
efeffraie beaucoup de monde. Ce
prprojet c'est fait. C'est comme
sisi on avait les deux modèles
dedevant nous.
- - Ce que j'aimerais, et c'est
popour ça que j'ai critiqué la
cocommission leurrant la semaine
papassée, c'est bien beau les
bebeaux sentiments, mais il
fafaudrait peut-être à un moment
dodonné au Québec regarder les
fafaçons de faire dans le systèe
pupublic et parapublic, parce qe
ququelque chose ne fonctionne p.
LaLa santé, la protection de la
jejeunesse, la ligne bleue. Le
REREM, j'aime autant que ça se
fafasse trop vite, mais qu'est-e
quque ça fasse.
- - Qui a mis 14 comités sur le
dodos de la STM? C'est le
gogouvernement du Québec. À un
momoment donné, c'est ça qui est
lele problème. Quand on veut nor
son n chien, on sait qu'il a la
rarage...
lele métro de bien marchait.
- - J'abonde dans le même sens.i
onon avait donné les mêmes moye,
onon n'en serait pas là en ce
momoment. Il ne faut pas comparr
dedes pommes avec des oranges.
- - Ce n'est pas une question de
cuculture et de multitude de
cocomités, DSI, de ça.
- - Oui c'est en partie une
ququestion de culture. Une
ququestion qu'on peut se poser :
esest-ce qu'en dessous de ça, il
n'n'y a pas le fait que la ligne
blbleue et dans le domaine
mumunicipal à Montréal et l'aut,
c'c'est le gouvernement du Québc
dede François Legault. Mme Plane
n'n'a jamais été capable de
s's'affirmer au gouverneme